[Música]
como culpable se declaró el primer
soldado ruso cruzado de crímenes de
guerra desde que inició la invasión a
ucrania el juicio no se realiza en
quiere y el uniformado de 21 años podría
enfrentar cadena perpetua
el presidente de nicaragua daniel ortega
dijo que no le interesaba asistir a la
cumbre de las américas a menos de un mes
de este evento que se realizará en los
ángeles la polémica sigue porque la casa
blanca no tiene la intención de invitar
a ese país ni tampoco a cuba ni a
venezuela aunque todavía no mandan las
invitaciones oficiales
y las elecciones masculina y femenina de
eeuu recibirán el mismo salario y las
mismas bonificaciones luego de que la
federación de fútbol hueso care
oficializará el acuerdo por el que tanto
lucharon y las jugadoras el convenio se
extiende hasta el año 2020
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
los saluda maría clara calle y para mí
como siempre es un gusto saludarlos y
comencemos con la actualidad hablando
del primer juicio por crímenes de guerra
en ucrania y es que este miércoles el
soldado acusado de matar a un civil
desarmado se declaró culpable
el uniformado ruso de 21 años
enfrentaría una sentencia a cadena
perpetua y lo acusan de asesinato
premeditado sin embargo rusia dice que
no tiene información sobre el militar
que enfrenta el juicio les contamos
todos los detalles del caso en el
siguiente informe
se ha convertido en el primer rostro de
los presuntos crímenes de guerra rusos
vadim si si marín de 21 años está
acusado de matar a un hombre desarmado
de 62 en la región de schumi al noreste
del país en febrero apenas unos días
después de que comenzara la invasión él
y otros cuatro soldados supuestamente
robaron un vehículo y estaban huyendo
cuando se encontraron con el hombre y lo
mataron para evitar ser denunciados la
fiscal superior de ucrania dice que el
juicio que tienen lugar en medio del
conflicto en curso
de entregar un mensaje con este primer
juicio estamos enviando una señal clara
de que todos los autores todas las
personas que ordenaron o ayudaron a
cometer crímenes en ucrania no podrán
evitar su responsabilidad también están
en marcha varias investigaciones
internacionales con la participación de
la onu y la corte penal internacional
muchas se centran en el suburbio de
busca en kiev donde se encontraron los
cadáveres de cientos de civiles tras la
retirada de las tropas rusas a
principios de abril mientras tanto los
fiscales ucranianos avanzan en la
investigación de más de 11.000 casos y
se espera que otros dos también se
desarrollen rápidamente un soldado ruso
será juzgado en ausencia por violación y
asesinato mientras que el juicio contra
dos soldados acusados de disparar
cohetes contra civiles en la región
nororiental de jarquín comenzará el
jueves en lo que puede leerse como un
intento por salvar la cumbre de las
américas eeuu suavizó en varias de las
sanciones que tiene contra cuba y
venezuela esto luego de que los
mandatarios de méxico bolivia y
guatemala se negaron a asistir a la
reunión que se realizará los ángeles
estos y la casa blanca no invita a cuba
venezuela y nicaragua sin embargo las
invitaciones aún no han sido enviadas a
pesar de esto el mandatario nicaragüense
daniel ortega respondió que no le
interesa asistir a la cumbre gabriel
colchón nos cuenta cómo está el panorama
diplomático a menos de tres semanas de
la cumbre de las américas que debe tener
lugar en los ángeles del 6 al 10 de
junio algunas tensiones emergieron en el
continente guatemala informó que no
participará en el evento mientras que
méxico honduras y bolivia que
condicionaron su presencia a la
invitación de nicaragua cuba y venezuela
que en principio fueron excluidos de
ella por eeuu de la cumbre
podría
a ayudar
e iniciar una política nueva y le tengo
confianza
al presidente baile él podría
[Música]
día será tras política
anacrónica de subordinación de falta de
respeto a la independencia a la
soberanía de los pueblos de los países
para aliviar las tensiones
joe biden anunció el martes el
levantamiento de algunas sanciones
económicas contra venezuela y al mismo
tiempo el gobierno de nicolás maduro y
la oposición informaron de la
reanudación de sus negociaciones para
ponerle fin a la crisis y méxico reiteró
su disposición para hacer el anfitrión
un día antes la casa blanca también
notificó de la flexibilización de
algunas de sus medidas contra cuba con
el restablecimiento de vuelos
comerciales o la reactivación del
programa de reunificación familiar
decisiones que no acaban de convencer a
la isla el bloqueo
del bloque económico como lo conocemos
hoy es un componente fundamental
continúa totalmente en pie y continúa
afecto continuó afectando el desempeño
de la economía en vísperas de la cumbre
de las américas la primera dama jill
biden inició una gira de seis días en
américa latina donde está previsto que
visite ecuador panamá y costa rica en
américa aumentaron un 27% los nuevos
contagios por covite 19 la semana pasada
así lo reveló la organización
panamericana de la salud en el último
mes la pandemia se ha propagado de
manera constante en el continente por lo
que las hospitalizaciones crecieron en
18 países centroamérica fue la región
donde más aumentaron los casos con un
80% más de positivos que la medición
anterior ante el panorama la ope ese
alerta que la situación puede empeorar
la semana pasada nuestra región registró
más de 900 18.000 casos lo cual
representa un aumento del 27,2 por
ciento en comparación con la semana
anterior se registraron más de 3500
muestres las hospitalizaciones por kobe
19 aumentaron en 18 países y las
admisiones a unidades de cuidados
intensivos
aumentaron en 13 países y territorios
las elecciones masculina y femenina de
fútbol en eeuu lograron un acuerdo con
la federación y hueso care para que
tanto las mujeres como los hombres
tengan el mismo salario además recibirán
los mismos premios y bonificaciones
y colectivo se extiende hasta el año
2028 previo a esto australia era el
único país que había conseguido logros
de igualdad salarial en este deporte
una decisión histórica por la igualdad
salarial en el fútbol la federación de
eeuu ue soccer oficializó el acuerdo con
el que las jugadoras y jugadores
recibirán el mismo sueldo las mismas
bonificaciones y los mismos premios en
metálico incluidos los de la copa del
mundo 6 este es un momento
verdaderamente histórico para el fútbol
en eeuu y para el fútbol en general
somos el primer país que lo hace edad
también se comprometió a compartir en
partes iguales una fracción de sus
ingresos por transmisiones socios y
patrocinios y mejorará la salud la
privacidad y la seguridad de las
jugadoras pago igualitario por un
trabajo igualitario en el fútbol de eeuu
es un momento histórico para este equipo
estoy muy orgullosa de todo el trabajo
realizado para conseguirlo en 2019 el
combinado femenino obtuvo un bono de 110
mil dólares por haber ganado el mundial
mientras que los hombres recibieron 407
mil dólares a pesar de que no
consiguieron clasificarse a la cita en
disparidades como esa terminarán con las
nuevas condiciones se estima que entre
2000 y 2028 una jugadora podría ganar
anualmente 450 mil dólares y participe
en todas las convocatorias sin contar
mundiales en 2018 esa compensación
habría sido de 245 mil dólares
es un momento de cambio de juego aquí en
eeuu pero tiene el potencial de cambiar
la forma en la que el fútbol
internacional y el deporte internacional
hacen negocios en action sports internas
en febrero de este año y hueso que
compensó a la selección femenina con 24
millones de dólares por los partidos
disputados entre 2015 y 2019 periodo en
el que ganaron dos mundiales
precisamente ese episodio zanjaba una
parte de la demanda que se remonta a
2016 cuando algunas jugadoras incluida
la ganadora del balón de oro de 2019
megan rapinoe denunciaron que se les
pagaba menos que a la selección
masculina pese a que ellas generaban más
ingresos para la federación de fútbol
del país
y para terminar les vamos a mostrar un
dibujo recientemente descubierto
hablamos del primer desnudo conocido que
pintó el artista
miguelangel este miércoles se vendió en
una subasta en christie's en parís y
valió más de 23 millones de euros un
récord para una de las obras del maestro
italiano la obra había sido designada
tesoro nacional francés lo que impedía
que fuera exportado del país durante 30
meses pero ahora el gobierno eliminó la
designación lo que permitió que este
dibujo se ofreciera sin restricciones a
coleccionistas de todo el mundo se cree
que un hombre desnudo y dos figuras
detrás como es llamada es una de las
primeras obras de miguel ángel que data
de finales del siglo xv
y con estas imágenes nos despedimos pero
los invitamos a que sigan conectados con
france24
[Música]